ethan is this a one-time confidence
shock or is this a start to a prolonged
period of risk off kind of like in 2011
to 2012 well I think there'll be a risk
off for a little while here because
nothing's gonna get resolved around the
UK in the next few months I mean they
they don't even have clarity around
who's gonna run the new government as
your earlier guest said the the two
parties have leadership battles going on
they're not even gonna start the process
of renegotiating until October so this
is gonna hang over the UK for a long
time I think the spillover to the rest
of the world depends very much on what
happens in the rest of Europe if if we
started hearing about exit talk in other
countries then this becomes a much
bigger more systemic problem for the
global economy right now it looks like
it's mainly the UK with some spillover
to Europe but if we start hearing more
exit stories it becomes much more
concerning even it seems pretty clear
that there's going to be at least in the
short term or medium term some sort of
confident shock decline in investment in
the real economy to what extent does the
weakening pound help cushion that does
that help stimulate investment in the UK
or does it merely just reflect the rush
of capital of the exits yeah I mean it's
a pretty soft buffer I mean this is this
is a big hit to confidence the pound is
falling because of the collapse in
confidence we are economists in London
are expecting a three quarter long
recession in the UK and lost GDP growth
of two and a half percent so it's a full
recession the pound helps a little bit
so in terms of parts of the economy that
are hurt more than others trade oriented
companies may do ok with their you know
with their exports on the other hand
anything that's related to long-term
purchases that consumers are knocking on
want to make big commitments in terms of
auto sales companies are going to hold
back on investment until they see
clarity around where things are going so
there's an uncertainty shock that really
causes kind of a way
see attitude the economy that's not good
for growth even what a negative rates do
for the state of investments in state of
confidence here I have a chart on my
terminal and looks at not just the
negative rates that the BOE or the BOJ
are using but real rates here on 10-year
government debt you can see that the
white line is the u.s. we're still a
slightly positive here but Japanese real
rates of course are negative and British
real rates are negative 1.5% of me just
moving massively down what does that do
well I mean lower interest rates and
negative interest rates do encourage
people to move out of fixed income
investments away from those negative
earning assets into riskier investments
like the stock market and the credit
markets but clearly there's a double
message to investors in the one hand you
want to move out to more riskier assets
and the other hand the fact that rates
are in this negative it makes you
worried that the world really is a very
unhealthy place and so there's a kind of
confidence component to this so I think
when central bank's move their own rates
nominal interest rates into negative
territory that that connective
confidence effect pretty much cancelled
out the stimulant of effect of the lower
interest rates so it's a it's a
challenging situation for central banks
no question about it